هذه هي الصورة التي يريد
طالبان طرحها بطريقة ودية ورعوية تجلب السلام والأمن في شوارع مدينة
غازني.
الحمد
لله ، الرجل يقول
أنه قد يكون أداءً جيدًا
لكاميراتنا ، لكن هذا يخبر طالبان
يريد أن يظهر أنهم قد تغيروا
عندما تتحدث إلى الرجال
وبعضهم ليس لديه لحى طويلة أنت.
نقول لهم أي شيء عن
لحاهم أو هل هو مهم الآن
نقول للناس أن هذا هو
النبي محمد سنة
ونعلمهم كما يقول ولكن لا نريد أن
نجبر الناس على فعل ذلك
في جزء آخر من السوق.  تحرص هيئة
الأمر بالمعروف والنهي عن المنكر التي تم إحياؤها حديثًا
على إظهار أنها تتخذ
لمسة أخف ،
فهي تجمع أصحاب المتاجر لتقديم
أنفسهم وتحذيرهم من
أهمية اتباع الشريعة الإسلامية.
تأكد من أن نسائك يغطين أنفسهن
ويخبر أحد الطلاب الحشد أنه لا ينبغي لهن
السفر بدون قريب من الذكور.
نشر الفضيلة
ومنع الرذيلة التي لا يزال الرجال
يستقرون
فيها حتى وقت قريب كانت هذه هي الوزارة
للنساء ، ويبدو الرجل المسؤول الآن متوجسًا من
وجودي ويرفض أن يلقى عيني
يقول إن مهمتهم هي مساعدة الأفغان على
اعتناق الحكم الإسلامي
و  ماذا تفعل إذا كانوا لا
يتبعون تفسيرك للشريعة الإسلامية ،
فنحن نتصرف وفقًا لأحكام الشريعة الإسلامية ،
أولاً نقوم بإبلاغ الناس
بالأفعال الصالحة
التي نكرز بها ونقوم بتوصيل
الرسالة إليهم بطريقة لطيفة
في المرة الثانية التي نكررها لهم
مرة أخرى
وفي المرة الثالثة نتحدث معهم
بقسوة طفيفة
إذا كانت كلماته تبدو وكأنها نقاط نقاش
فذلك لأنهم
كما نتركه يسلمنا إصدارًا حديثًا
يوضح كتيب طالبان الذي يلخص نهج المجموعة
اللطيف ،
لذلك يقول أن هذا الكتاب يحتوي على
القواعد الخاصة بكيفية تنفيذ
عملهم ،
لكن العادات القديمة تموت بشدة وتعود إلى
كابول ، فمن الواضح أن الجميع لا
يتبع الإرشادات الجديدة ،
إنها كدمات شديدة في مكان آمن
وحيد.  يُظهر لنا العلامات القبيحة التي
خلفها بعد أن قال إنه تعرض للجلد من قبل
مقاتلي طالبان ، لقد غيرنا اسمه
لحمايته ، يخبرنا أن ثلاثة مقاتلين أوقفوه
في دوار مزدحم لارتدائه
ملابس على الطراز الغربي
أخذوه إلى كوخ حراسة
وطالبوه  لرؤية هاتفه الخلوي ،
كانت لدي صور في هاتفي تتعلق بالمثليين ،
كما أن الملابس التي كنت أرتديها كانت على
غرار مثلي الجنس
عندما كانوا يضربونني ظلوا
يقولون إنني مثلي الجنس يجب أن
أقتل
، وكان لديهم وجوه مخيفة للغاية
كانوا يستمتعون بالضرب  لقد
كانت الوحشية المروعة معروضة بالكامل
قبل أسابيع في مدينة هيرات الغربية
عندما تم تعليق جثث أربعة رجال ملطخة بالدماء
في الأماكن العامة ليتمكن الجميع من
رؤية طالبان.  ساعدهم على أنهم كانوا خاطفين
قتلوا خلال مداهمة
على صدر أحد الرجال ،
وسيُعاقب الخاطفون مثل هذا التحذير
القاتم الذي يبدو أن العديد من الحشد
يوافقون على عرض طالبان في العصور الوسطى ،
فالناس سعداء حقًا بهذا
القرار الذي قاله هذا الرجل لأن الناس
يعتقدون أنه من خلال القيام بذلك.
يمكن إزالة هذا الاختطاف من هذه المحافظة
في عرض بشع آخر تم إذلال اثنين من
المجرمين المزعومين الذين رسموا وجوههم
أمام حشد ساخر ،
وهو عقاب تفضله طالبان على
اللصوص الصغار
بعد فساد الحكومة السابقة التي
استغلت المجموعة
رغبة مسعورة في تحقيق العدالة السريعة.
لكنهم يتمتعون بالذكاء الكافي ليعرفوا كيف
يبدو الأمر لبقية العالم
مرة أخرى في غزني ، فإن محاولاتنا لرؤية
نظام العدالة في العمل قد تم إيقافها مرارًا وتكرارًا
قيل لنا أن المحكمة الشرعية العليا
مغلقة على الرغم من الأشخاص الذين ينتظرون في
الخارج.  في محاولة لإظهار أن لديك
كما نحاول إقناع طالبان للسماح لنا بالدخول
نرى رجلين يتجهان إلى المحكمة.
ينسحب قائد طالبان لدينا ويسمح لنا بمتابعتهم
ولكن في قاعة المحكمة يوضح القاضي
أننا غير مرحب
بهم لأنهم لا يسمحون لنا ولكنهم أيضًا
لن يعطونا
سببًا لأن ما يحدث خلف
الأبواب المغلقة هنا ليس كذلك '  تتناسب مع
صورة طالبان الجديدة المصقولة بعناية
وأن الحركة التي ولدت في الصراع
لا تزال وحشية في جوهرها